summerlin parade is back in person last
year
it was virtual with the online broadcast
receiving an emmy nom
sherry and brian will host by being in
the parade along with jacy fernandez and
mercedes martinez
mercedes joins us now with the preview
look at this stuff isn't it neat i feel
like i'm
ariel and this is a party it is
america's birthday party celebration put
on by the summerlin council
and i am on the under the sea float
apparently i won't be in the parade on
this float but i will be a part of it
along with jc
also sheri swensk and brian loftus
we are so excited that the parade is
back this year
it is america's birthday party parade
put on by the summerlin council
and what to expect this year well it's
an abbreviated version it's only 30
minutes this year
but we're just so bad happy it's back in
person we're still gonna have
all of the entertainment and the
pageantry that you're used to
we're talking about floats the drumbots
the desert angels gospel choir
the west las vegas arts center dancers
still walkers you name it
we're going to have it and the big
balloons too it's all happening but it
is on
july 3rd this year so you can spend july
4th with your family but come on down
july 3rd starts at 9 00 a.m
up in summerlin and it's going to be an
amazing time
and we just want to be part of your
world we'll send it back to you